quel 20 ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovi diosono fa vj oggi siamo sub
abissi moon dei propri simulator che
cazzo di nome deve ricominciare perché
credo sia un gioco più bello del del
secolo ragazzi allora non capito eh beh
è già partito e già bellissimi premi e
per prendere la spada con la spada a
questa è la spada perfetta la sua è la
madonna skyrim che bel gioco cosa faccio
ora madonna che alberi mai come sembrano
avere le foglie come dopo nel dettaglio
infinitesimale di quest'albero dov'era
minimo giorno c'è della jenny hanno
ucciso fantastico e della gente che mi
sta guardando bene sono degli stronzi
che dovrei far fuori cosa dovrebbe
essere un tipo di ballo moderno ragazzi
c'è della gente brutta che mi sta
guardando che si muovo vabbè certo ecco
come sono combattivi ragazzi i goblin a
dio è un uomo armato di ascia [ __ ]
amici palestrato zio come svengono
quando dico cosa fa e michael jackson
andato a controllare sul suo amico era
morto che si è accorto che in realtà è
morto ed è svenuto anche lui io non so
perché ho giocato a skyrim per tanto
tempo quando c'è la sta cosa
ciao frate è tutto a posto 6 sculettando
perché ti sei reso conto di esser sexy
ti possa uccidere incrocio tra gandalf
ghibli perfetto ma a partire farsi
venire la gente posso fare perché finché
che mazzata credo che sia ufficialmente
il gioco dell'anno regale meraviglioso
che cazzo guardi che bella faccia che
azzariti devo ucciderti ecco mi spiace
ci stiamo avvicinando a questo mega
dildo c'è un blocco stradale ma clan dei
fucili ragazzi non posso ucciderli
normalmente questi c'è un arco c'è un
arco perfetto
adesso posso ucciderli a distanza
perfetto mi spiace fratello non era non
volevo però devo ucciderti con l'arco
che bello che delle chiavette e adesso
si fa sul serio cazzo
aveva solo un proiettile ed era una
donna e ai peli sulle braccia lasciamo
perdere le armi che sono inutili
ammazziamo la gente che non ho ancora
capito perché non vogliono uccidere
prova beh ragazzi siete tutti degli
gnocchi mancati i modelli di abercrombie
fatevelo dire però vabbè
quella volta che ti sei beccato una
freccia nel ginocchio da ricordi
perfetto quest'albero è decisamente più
bello di tutti gli altri no cosa corri
cosa corri
[Musica]
beh
ma devi correre basta e poi si fermano i
ragazzi perché mista spara ma cosa
volete la mia vita fatemi capire chuck
norris sei un frigo che se sei un uomo
ai le tette amico mio non lo voglio
sapere ci ho ripensato amico mio tu hai
dei capelli che sono da favola credimi e
sei anche tu un uomo mai le tette
lui invece sei una donna e non ce l'hai
le tette qual è il problema di questo
gioco aveva un'idea sbagliata alle sesso
femminile di quello maschile il creatore
di sto gioco vero ho trovato un jeff
beck rega come funziona con tasto destro
perfetto
devo andare lì sopra chiesto spari che
non mi prendi tanto volo ai vai vai vai
vai va non ho la più pallida idea di
dove stia andando però va bene può
scalare sta tutta natali di grattacielo
per un attimo se l'aspetto jazz ma no
come non mi fa andare più di così c'è un
tempio sensei la sudici trova kung fu
panda
no kung fu coniglio ragazzi cè un coni
non ci voglio più andare là sopra che
c'è un coniglio che fa accapponare la
pelle
ciao zio cosa ti spari con quel di
indovinati mi ha ucciso vai di spada vai
di spada forza è fottutamente
impossibile ti prego dimmi che non mi
far iniziare da zero ti prego tua madre
[ __ ] mashhad che lo scalo anche
senza oggetto extralusso ma [ __ ] e
non crepa ryan dunn crepano anche la
spada caso vuole morire dove morì arti
pure la famiglia
e morto così è morto ho guadagnato anche
questa pistola al plasma al plasma a
parte questo dico che sparacio qualcosa
utile graphic settings ah beh allora è
bene migliorata molto si tratta di un
gioco di un certo di un certo valore
comunque cosa corre basta non correre
cioè quella roba lì tra l'altro è morto
ucciso al caso
fatemi salire qua sopra che non vedo c'è
un tizio sei tu no vabbè questo ragazzi
ha vinto lui ha vinto la vita non so chi
sia ma gesù santo e che cosa fai vara
che la danza classica non si fa quasi
quota zero de lucci dati mi dispiace
cosa ti tocchi il clou lo nomini male
che a prendere il jetpack e volare in
posti ignoti che non ho ancora capito
quali dovrebbero essere però sa andare
via di qua delle montagne montagne
abello vedo che l'hanno rifinito molto
bene questo gioco mi rimane soltanto una
cosa da fare non posso buttarmi giù che
fai ma come va dai già che fai una cosa
che non esiste almeno che ci fosse ma
[ __ ] va bè ragazzi
questo era bobby simulator piaciuto
proprio tanto soprattutto nella parte in
cui alduin è morto mio gioco preferito
una volta era metal gear solid diventato
questo adesso è diventato bobby
simulator se mi chiedete ogni volta fa
rima questo videogioco preferito questo
quali non so se avete notato la cosa
bella di tutto questo è che quando tiri
fuori il mitra il gancetto sbatte ed è
da questi piccoli dettagli che si
capisce quando un videogioco è una bomba
pazzesca e quindi ragazzi che con questa
incredibile vista che vi lascio perché è
godibile ogni volta che scoprite di
giocare un qualche cosa che poi risulta
essere un gioco di merda cliccate su
questo video guardate un po questa roba
perché di sicuro non è peggio quindi
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto un mi
piace se anche voi pensate che questo
sia di duke è il migliore del mondo
perché io personalmente lo penso
come al solito ragazzi se il video è
piaciuto lasciato sgomento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e con ogni
nota la prescrizione sono stati discreti
ci vediamo al prossimo guido belle
ragazze